what do you pray for Ser Jorah oh I pray
for home - what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another game
of thrones season eight prediction video
I have been making a lot of character
breakdown videos lately and they are
mostly about what I think will happen
was some of the main characters but I
wanted to make a video about a character
that doesn't get as much recognition so
today I want to talk about sir Jorah
Mormont I want to discuss how I think
Jorah Mormont story could end I have
been rereading the bulks and I came
across something that I thought was
interesting and I wanted to run it by
you just to see what you think about
this possibility before season 7 came
out I made a video about Jorah Mormont
and in that video I predicted Jorah
would survive the entire series but I
remember some people commenting on that
video and they were saying they actually
think Jorah will die I know some people
believe Jorah will sacrifice himself in
some way to save Daenerys Targaryen
that's actually not a bad prediction we
know how Jorah feels about Daenerys and
I am sure Jorah would do just about
anything for Daenerys at this point even
if that means giving his own life Jorah
kind of proved this in season 7 when he
volunteered to go beyond the wall he did
not have to do that in Daenerys even
advised against it but Jorah was willing
to go to show that he could still serve
the Narus in any way possible but with
that being said I still don't believe
Jorah will die I don't think he would
need to sacrifice himself to save
Daenerys although I won't completely
rule that out because it is possible in
my opinion Jorah still needs to finish
his own character arc and in season 8 we
will finally see this come to fruition
before I go any further let me give you
a little bit of the backstory first that
way everything will make sense as most
of you should know Joris father was
giora Mormont
he was the Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch at the beginning of the story but
some of you may not know why his father
was actually in the Nights
watch in the first place giora Mormont
was the Lord of Bear Island in head of
house Mormont
but he gave up his seat of power and
joined the Nights Watch that way his son
Jorah could take over Bear Island as
soon as possible
giora Mormont did not have to join the
Nights Watch it wasn't like he broke any
laws or anything like that he only
joined so that his son could take over
Bear Island in his place after he joined
the Nights Watch that was when Jorah
became the head of house Mormont and he
eventually married a woman who was
accustomed to living a lavish lifestyle
you sold slaves I
why no money an expensive wife where is
she now in another place
with another man we have all seen Bear
Island and it's not really the type of
place that is known for having fancy
dinners and tournaments and things like
that but Jorah went above and beyond to
try and please this wife that he had
Jorah was having singers and musicians
come to Bear Island to play for her and
he even paid chefs to come in and make
these big extravagant dinners but he
eventually ran out of money he can no
longer afford to keep up with the type
of lifestyle his wife wanted so he
eventually started to sell poachers into
slavery to make some extra cash but
people found out and this was
devastating news especially for Giora
Mormont his son was now the disgraced
Knight who had to live the rest of his
life in exile because of his crimes I
brought shame into my house I broke my
father's heart I've forfeited the right
to claim this soul
it's yours now can you imagine how Jorah
must have felt about this his father
gave up his life for the Nights Watch
so that Jorah could take over the house
and now Jorah is on the run and living
his life in exile which means his father
pretty much joined the Nights Watch for
nothing
Jorah can no longer rule bare Iowan
which is all his father ever wanted
Jorah Mormont had brought great shame on
his house but there is still time for a
second chance Jorah does not have to die
before he can be respected in the eyes
of his family and the entire north again
you have to think they are keeping this
character alive for a reason I don't
think they cured his greyscale just to
kill him off later that really wouldn't
make a whole lot of sense they could
have just killed him then he must still
have a purpose and a role to play in my
opinion as of right now Jorah is
currently on his way north with the rest
of John and Danny's party and when they
arrive Jorah will finally see his family
again
but Lyanna Mormont isn't just going to
forgive Jorah for everything he had done
Lyanna Mormont shows no mercy but when
she finds out Jorah went beyond the wall
with their king in the north
she will at least hear him out and give
him a chance to speak we already know
Jon isn't holding anything against him
Jon said he was glad Ned Stark didn't
take off his head for selling poachers
into slavery your father wanted to
execute me you know I heard he was in
the rice it was it made me hate him any
less I'm glad I didn't catch it
me too John and Jorah was able to bond a
little bit and this relationship will
only grow stronger in the episodes to
come we have also seen Jorah form a
relationship with Saemaul Tarly Sam
immediately had respect for Jorah just
because his father was G or Mormont Sam
was willing to risk his own life to save
jours just out of the love that he had
for his father and this could be setting
up something we will see in the future I
owe my life and you see father saved me
more than once it's the least I could do
oops a pause will cross again
but before we get to the final episode
we will have to see the Great War play
out first personally I don't see Samwell
Tarly doing much fighting in that war
there is something Sam can provide
though other than just his intelligence
Sam currently has his father's Valyrian
steel sword hearts bane he took it to
the Citadel with him and he took it to
Winterfell with him when he left old
town this sword has also stayed in the
plot for a reason as well I believe Sam
will allow Jorah to wield this sword in
the war to come
this sword would be a lot more effective
if it was in Joris hands instead of
Sam's right now it's looking like Sam
and bran will continue to work together
in order to find a way to stop the night
king and if that's the case Sam can let
someone else use his father's sword
since Sam and Jorah have already become
friends he seems like the best option
right now
Jorah Mormont might be an old man but he
can still kick some ass and if he had a
Valyrian steel sword to use he could do
even more damage than he did when he was
using those dragon glass daggers beyond
the wall but what I really want to talk
about is what will ultimately happen to
Jorah at the end of this story assuming
he survives the war what would he do
next there is a chance Sam might be the
one to tell Jorah where to go next
some of you may not know this but when
Joris father died he actually had one
dying wish and he told this the same ol
Tarly right before he died after Lord
Commander Mormont was stabbed he was
laying in Samwell Tarly arms as he was
bleeding out and Sam was doing
everything that
could to comfort him as he was dying but
G or as Sam to do one thing his
breathing became very shallow and his
voice was almost a whisper but what he
said to Sam was tell my son Jorah tell
him take the black my wish dying wish
tell Jorah forgive him my son please go
as gr Mormont was dying in Sam's arms he
only wanted Sam to do one thing and that
was to find his son Jorah Mormont and
tell him his father's dying wish was for
him to take the black and join the
Nights Watch Jorah never got to see his
father again and all this time he has
felt ashamed that he dishonored his
house especially considering his father
left him in charge after he joined the
Nights Watch so Jorah could inherit Bear
Island if Sam told Jorah that was his
father's dying wish I believe he would
want to honor that Jorah would see that
as trying to make amends for how he had
broken his father's heart all those
years ago but what I want to ask all of
you is do you think Jorah could do
something like this I think it is
possible but the only problem I have
what this is I'm not so sure there will
still be a Night's Watch there are no
more humans living beyond the wall and
if the night king and his army are
completely destroyed then there wouldn't
be a need for the wall who would the
Nights Watch need to defend the realm
against if everything north of the wall
was dead I could see Jorah trying to
fill his father's shoes in his sense but
if the Nights Watch is disbanded then he
would need to do this in another way if
the Nights Watch still exists at the end
of the show then I think this is a good
possibility for Jorah he could be the
1,000th Lord Commander and that does
have a nice ring to it either way I
believe Jorah will survive all the
fighting he has survived greyscale
already and they are going to kill him
off before he can redeem himself in his
family's eyes he has made some mistakes
like all of us but Jorah is a really
good man and he deserves to live a
normal life after everything that he has
been through but this is just my opinion
and you certainly have the right to
disagree let me know your thoughts on
Jorah Mormont's fate do you believe he
will honor his father's dying wish or do
you think Jorah will die in the end I'm
really curious to see what you think but
before I go I want to thank everybody
for watching the video I really do
appreciate that and I hope everybody has
a great day I will see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]